is kiki someone that you would love to
have join you permanently on the reel
she's that young fresh fearless girl
that we really really love and you know
the viewers learn
so much they love when she comes on when
you get unemployed kiki call us
it's a treat for people like me who love
watching you on the reel how are things
going
still taping the reel at home you know
it's been a blessing
i mean to be able to steal work has been
a blessing because if we
just decided as a tv show just to stay
at home we're all in each other's homes
you know and i'm like i got the lights
i'm like lonnie love studios
i think now that the show has actually
changed because now we have
really more meaningful to meet
conversations
is you you can't rely on okay maybe i
can do this or
i can do something physical you really
have to have deep
topics deep conversations to keep
people's attention
beginning of the season was election
season so we were having kamala harris
and
and you know elizabeth warren on and
having those type of conversations
but we were also having you know
relationships and funny conversations
so it the the show has changed but it
it's actually gotten better
but you've had no shortage of incredible
guests joining you throughout the years
you had kiki palmer on i believe it was
last week
yes we love kiki i just think it's
important to shout each other out and
say hey i see you you're doing good
take it easy on yourself i don't know if
you ever read the comments but
i started to to dissect them and the
overwhelming
feeling from the fans was that it felt
like she was a castmate it felt like she
was a co-host with you guys that it's
just so natural the chemistry between
the five of you do you ever want to get
back to the original format of the show
with five co-hosts
is kiki someone that you would love to
have join you permanently on the reel
i would love it the thing is kiki always
working this is what we can't ever get
kiki
it's hustlers olay yeah she's got her
hand in the middle telling you kiki stay
working so if we could ever like lock
her down
she would definitely because she know
she's that young fresh
fearless you know girl that we really
really love
and you know the viewers learn so much
they love when she comes on and i love
when she comes on too so
when you get unemployed kiki call us
have you put the buzz in her ear is this
something that you've talked about
i always put it in her ear listen there
are a lot of people
i'm like hey you know if you you ever
need
you know just come on over come on over
who else who else have you said it too
oh i love
a lot of people i love people like
angela rye
i love anybody like political um i love
and i like to have like more mothers on
the show because i know we're a diverse
show
but i like more latinas i like more
asians
new people always keep the the
conversation fresh
so that's why you know that's why
garcelle is working out
so well right now i mean she has so much
experience
she's seasoned garcelle
season everybody please give it up for
the wonderful
garcia bovee garcia
what has it been like having garcelle
join you and the ladies on the show
she's a good time and she has the
greatest sense of humor
and she's also said angle right now so
you know i like looking out for her i'm
helping
her fine dude yeah she is just
a full package and we're just happy to
have her i want to ask you about one
more name that's very special to me
because if raven simone joined you
on the rio alongside adrian it would be
my unofficial
cheetah girl's reunion that i've been
hoping for and holding out hope for
is raven a name two seasons ago we had
raven come
on and it was just so magical seeing her
and
adrienne i would love
that and you know she's such a fearless
person
plus the disney stories i would love it
okay so you would like to see the show
add in a fifth permanent oh as many
people as we can fit
yeah 50 co-hosts we'll just kind of you
know
just come on let's just you know of
course it's not my show
so i can't but okay right okay but we
will hold out hope i would love to see
raven or kiki alongside you because i do
agree that they do bring something to
the table that's very special and
different from what the rest of you
bring
and young cause i'm getting oh so come
on
i do want to ask you because i know you
and tamara are
very close friends has it been strange
for you to go to work and not have her
there next to you
oh yes i always miss i miss her laugh
but the thing is she ain't going nowhere
she still called me
you know she bugging me she's with the
show yeah it's like she she's never left
the show really it's just
you know she's just not on our show and
it was just nice to have her come back
and return as a guest but i do miss her
but don't tell her don't tell i miss her
i was going to say lonnie you got to
keep it real with me are you
secretly like trying to convince tamara
to maybe come back have you ever said
that
i don't think she gonna do that so i i
interviewed tamara not long ago we had a
really really lovely conversation
and i loved how she described her life
in napa she said that
being in napa working at the winery she
feels
quote at peace i have
peace i have peace because i'm with my
family
and my family rejuvenates me
and i'm just wondering have you ever
thought about maybe
taking a pivot how will you know when
it's time for
you to leave the real and maybe go on to
to new projects
this is what i wanted to always do was
to be
an entertainer i mean i'm a comedian i'm
an author
you know i'm not a devoted wife and
mother
that's me was never in my in my plans
and right now i'm good i'm like so
happy that the show is taking this turn
where we are
um you know having the type of guests
that are
are interesting to our viewers and this
is something i've always wanted to do so
i don't know
when i'll leave um but i'm
good right now you know the last time we
spoke we talked so much about your
memoir i tried to change so you don't
have to
and you were very candid about you know
why you included
everything that played out with tamar in
your book i don't know if you heard her
podcast last week she said something
very interesting
i heard that that network that i was
working with
at the time would not sign off and
allowed
me and them girls to fall out in public
almost ruined my whole career my
livelihood
everything that i worked for and never
said
one time didn't say okay you to start a
network we're going to have a meeting
with you
we don't want you to do the show no more
at least give me a heads up
but no and then say nothing and allowed
lonnie to take the fall adrian jeannie
tamara and myself and we are here
battling and fight as
black ass black girls and they don't
care did you know that
no i didn't know that so that's wow
i mean you know i don't know how much of
that is true
i just feel bad because i know that i
didn't have anything to do with it
and so that's the you know i think
that's what i said in my book
so you know it's it's i hope that she
finds some closure
and like i said you know i try to you
know be there for
but i just want to make sure that i
don't trigger her you have any message
you want to send her
take care of your mental health girl
that's that's the
most important thing you're hosting the
salt and pepper
documentary special tell me why you
wanted to be a part of it are you a huge
salt and pepper fan
i've been a salt and pepper fans since
they started in 1985
i mean they used to have the asymmetric
haircut
i went and got the asymmetric haircut
you know and what i love about this
this movie is that it tells you
everything from the beginning
all the way the whole journey is covered
you know to be grammy-winning
hip-hop female artists you know that's
something that we don't see
even today and so they have stood the
test of time
i mean who didn't love push it you know
push it push
push it you're back on drag race your
guest judging on this season
everybody say lolli
what is it about drag race that you seem
to really love
so much when you see the queens and you
hear their stories you're like oh wow
and that's what really makes it
relatable plus it's the fashion
it's the glamour it's the clapbacks
honey i'm like they like have the best
clapbacks
ever as a judge what immediately wins
you over and what immediately turns you
off
a fly outfit i'm like i don't
they nip and tuck and they they do all
kind of thing
i'm like because i get you know i
actually get suggestions now you know
i'm getting tips
because i'm like whoa that wig really
does look good
can i find it what makes me not want to
give a good score
is if like if they're not
being themselves because see just
because it's drag you're transforming
but you got to show something that makes
it
stand out but it has to also be
authentically you but who do you think
is most likely to find themselves in the
top three this season
oh gosh um
i think it will be rose tina berner
i think got mick would do it too do you
have a favorite holiday
yes brew valentine's day because i can
get some roses and some candy and i get
some
you